jean michel blanquer ministre de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse en
france depuis deux cent seulement il est
en visite à montréal à l'invitation du
grand festival le monde le quotidien le
monde et du conseil des relations
internationales de montréal corim
en conférence aujourd'hui demain il est
appelé à commenter le système éducatif
français la france étant l'un des
premiers pieds à voir implanter un
réseau gratuit de maternelle pour tous
les jeunes enfants et ça va jusqu'à
l'âge de trois ans je me laisse bonsoir
et bienvenue à 24,70 on a beaucoup parlé
d'éducation chez nous depuis depuis un
an surtout avec de nouvelles mesures
vous allez rencontrer monsieur roberge
notre ministre de l'éducation et vous
avez quelque chose en commun
vous avez été tous les deux enseignants
oui absolument
est ce que ça fait de vous deux
meilleurs ministres éducation avec une
meilleure vision s'est passé aux autres
le dire mais c'est vrai que c'est
toujours bien de contrats aidés mais
l'éducation et d'avoir ce goût pour la
transmission des savoirs et puis sur
goût des contacts avec leurs airs avec
les jeunes tout simplement
mais ça vous avez vécu les grandes
difficultés des systèmes d'éducation
pénurie d'enseignants des disques et
dans les écoles les inégalités vous avez
tous les cerveaux oui oui même si j'ai
surtout été professeur d'université et
j'ai surtout beaucoup regardez aussi les
autres systèmes éducatifs c'est toujours
beaucoup d'intérêt à comparer les
systèmes et c'est vrai que entre le
québec et la france il ya beaucoup de
points communs au moins quant aux défis
à relever et donc c'est toujours
intéressant de regarder comment font les
autres tout ça et vous parlez de
l'écraser la confiance vous oui c'est
bon c'est la devise en quelques semaines
j'ai choisi parce que le l'école de la
confiance signifie que je considère que
nos sociétés jeu pour parler de la
france ne sont pas assez des sociétés de
confiance qu'on a besoin de créer
beaucoup de confiance entre les gens et
beaucoup plus de confiance en soi chez
l'enfant aussi et ça passe d'abord et
avant tout par l'école par exemple en
m'apprenant dès qu'on arrive à l'école
maternelle a joué avec les autres a
gagné avec les autres
à être dans la confiance en soi aussi et
dans la confiance dans les autres parce
que l'école est le miroir de la société
aux fins oui la racine de la société
reste le miroir et vous et vous plaidez
de vous laver implanter les maternelles
trois ans ici sont les maîtres landel
quatre ans il ya eu des bonnes ya encore
des bases son implantation il si elles
sont volontaires chez vous ils sont
obligatoires elle l'était à 97% si je
comprends bien pour l'internet trois ans
mais vous avez rendu obligatoire à 100%
oui et pourquoi pourquoi si jeune si
petit si oui il ya plusieurs messages
derrière une telle mesure la poule
premier message c'est de dire l'école
maternelle c'est très important parce
que des choses essentielles se passe
pour l'enfant dans les premières années
de sa vie
c'est pourquoi on doit avoir des
politiques familiales pour la femme
enceinte pour toutes les premières
années de la vie est aussi une politique
de l' école préélémentaire donc de
l'école maternelle parce que on sait que
dès l'âge de trois ans il ya déjà de
grandes inégalités entre les enfants
liés aux circonstances familiales
d'autres deux enfants vous pouvez avoir
une différence de 1 à 4 contre au
vocabulaire maîtriser en raison du
vocabulaire qui lie à la maison et donc
si on veut lutter à la racine contre les
inégalités si on veut aussi un
épanouissement de l'enfant mais il faut
pouvoir garantir à tous les enfants
cet épanouissement dans le cadre de
l'école maternelle sinon quand il arrive
à 6 ans à l'école il ya déjà des très
grandes inégalités qui sont installés et
l'entrée dans la lecture et l'écriture
en particulier sera beaucoup plus
difficile pour un enfant qui arrive avec
un vocabulaire pauvres à l'école et la
maternelle c'est pour jouer socialiser
c'est apprendre des autres et en france
vous avez les crèches mais à 3 et 4 ans
vous n'avez pas ce que disent ils le
réseau de garderies où le ratio
éducateurs enfin et meilleur d'une
certaine manière oui alors après
population pour les québécois c'est
ainsi je le sais mais deux s'ils
voulaient ce qui est très important
c'est d'abord que cette école maternelle
vous l'avez dit sur une école de
l'épanouissement dire que comme c'est le
premier contact avec la avec l'école
qu'un enfant va avoir fort qu'il est
justement confiance dans cette école
dans cet endroit et ce soit un endroit
de bonheur d'endroits où on chante un
endroit où on dit des poèmes intendant
on raconte des histoires un endroit où
on joue ensemble et donc c'est ainsi
qu'il va rentrer sans même s'en rendre
compte dans des apprentissages j'insiste
beaucoup sur le langage en particulier
mais aussi sur le rapport à l'autre et
après chaque pays le fait selon les
modalités qui lui sont propres mais on
doit en effet être attentif à un bon
taux d'encadrement
on doit être attentif à des pédagogies
qui tiennent compte de ce qu'on sait
aujourd'hui sur les mécanismes
d'apprentissage de l'enfant pascal davoz
maternelle il ya plus d'enfants karens
qatar qu'il n'ya d'enfin paris scattered
un regard des risques et au maintien oui
c'est vrai mais ça peut changer dans le
futur c'est ce qu'on est en train de
changer
par exemple à le présenter à un public
emmanuel macron s'est engagé à ce que
dans les grandes sections de maternelle
donc pour les enfants de 5 ans on
réussisse à diviser par deux le nombre
de tes lèvres donc d'avoir douze élèves
par classe et qu'elle le sens pensez
vous que le québec pourrait être serrée
de votre système d'éducation
si l'un là où celle inverse on a
beaucoup à apprendre les uns des autres
voyez par exemple moi je dois améliorer
la direction d'école en france donner
plus de force aux directeurs et je sais
que je connais un peu le système
québécois et je sais qu'il ya des
inspirations apprendre ici
inversement notre expérience de l'école
maternelle la france est un le pays qui
a un peu inventé l'école maternelle 1 au
milieu du 19e siècle
peut être intéressante pour les réformes
que vous êtes en train de le faire nous
ça restera toujours sur une base
volontaire et de la liberté de choix
entre le cpe semble-t-il et la
maternelle
oui bien sûr je suis content je crois
que votre futur système c'est justement
de donner ce choix et c'est très bien
l'essentiel c'est qu'ils aient une
structure quel que soit le nom qu'on lui
donne
où l'enfant se trouve bien et où il va
pouvoir s'épanouir et vivre avec les
autres
vous savez bien que je veux parler de
laïcité oui parce qu'avec des
communications c'est tout ce qui se
passe va regarder un court extrait d'un
incident qui s'est produit parce que les
gens ne l'ont pas nécessairement réussie
vous souhaitez viral sur les réseaux
sociaux
sept mères accompagnatrices voilées qui
accompagnent la classe des enfants d'un
conseil régional de franche comté qui se
fait interpeller par un député de la
droite pour ne pas dire l'extrême droite
du rassemblement national on écoute je
demandais s'il vous plaît qui vient de
vendre
vous allez théâtre réagir là-dessus et
c'est ce que vous avez dit ma
déclaration étaient très banales sur les
très banal et pourtant c'est elle qui
fait controverse
rappelez vous ce que vous avez dit ce
n'était pas eux dit deux choses d'abord
j'ai condamné ce qui s'est passé là
c'est à dire que c'était nul et non
avenu ce qu'a fait ce monsieur puisqu'il
est habilité à le faire que par ailleurs
c'était enfin qui avait il a fait ça
devant les enfants fabriquent toutes
étaient toutes été a condamné dans ce
qu'il a fait c'est ce que j'ai fait et
puis après j'ai voulu résumer la cie la
situation juridique d'ailleurs pour les
accompagnatrices en disant pas interdit
mais mais pas souhaitable tout
simplement parce qu'en effet aujourd'hui
dans notre dans notre système lorsque il
ya éventuellement atteintes à l'ordre
public ou même mais l'idée qu'il puisse
y avoir du prosélytisme et bien les
directeurs d'école dans une situation de
éviter que l'accompagnatrice ce soit
voilée parce qu'elle les choix faits en
2004 parce qu'une loi sur la laïcité
depuis 2005 sur le voile à l'école
jusqu'à l'université en fait c'est un
choix
jusque jusqu'à l'entrée l'universal
entre à l'université c'est sans doute ce
sont des majeures c'était pour mettre
les enfants à l'abri de toute forme de
pression s'était créé un lieu de
neutralité religieuse de fait c'est le
raisonnement de base de la loi de 2004
qui est une réussite dans son
accomplissement
ces deux c'est tout simplement on doit
toujours partir de ce raisonnement là ça
comment on garantit à l'enfant à l'école
publique
un environnement de neutralité
religieuse et politique d'ailleurs
jusqu'à ce que j'aurai au parent qui
vient soul et l'accompagnement c'est une
situation un peu hybride parce que c'est
à la fois du temps scolaire donc on doit
être attentif et en même temps c'est en
dehors de l'espace scolaire c'est le
temps scolaire mais pas l'espace
scolaire 5
we draw message était très clair depuis
depuis deux ans et ses deux c'est que
c'est pas une loi qui nous permettra de
de changer les choses là-dessus par
contre il est bon qui est des bonnes
pratiques j'imagine que vous en avez
parlé avec monsieur robert je parce
qu'ici au québec on vient d'adopter une
loi ça s'est un peu d'ailleurs aux
petits enfants ça ne couvre pas les
garderies évidemment ça crée un petit
débat ici on dirait qu'une élection
fédérale qui s'est joué en partie là
dessus au québec pour vous c'était ici
on discute beaucoup de la discrimination
ceux qui s'opposent la loi d'ici la
discrimination c'est favoriser
l'exclusion pour vous non je pense que
c'est tout l'inversé je pense que vous
savez quand le concept républicain en
france le concept de d'une égalité des
citoyens c'est aussi le concept d'une
société ou parce que nous sommes égaux
ya pas de communautarisme et pas de
pression d'une religion sur sur une
autre et donc c'est au contraire la
meilleure façon de garantir l'égalité
entre les citoyens et la liberté de
conscience
précisément pour pouvoir croire ou ne
pas croire pour vous sentir tout
simplement à l'aise dans la société donc
des règles du jeu qui peuvent valoir
dans les services publics c'est pas la
même chose que dans l'espace public
en réalité s'agissant de l'école le
principe de base est assez clair c'est
garantir un espace de neutralité où il
n'y a pas de pression sur l'enfance et
cela le le le raisonnement de base tout
simplement monsieur le ministre merci
beaucoup
cette même date au et bon forum demain
merci dalle étant présentement marouane
chamakh qui a mis au monde c'est ce
réseau de garderies ministre
en tout cas beaucoup de choses
fructueuse à faire entre la france et le
québec en matière d'éducation et on se
sent vraiment très très relié dans ce
qu'il ya à faire dans le futur à s'aimer
refus du conseil merci à bras merci